This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford postdo
pathology, naturopathic doctor.
Hello everybody. Let's go ahead and open
up that waiting room and welcome to
Daily with Doc and Becca. My name is
Becca Dukes. I'm a certified holistic
health coach and also a certified
naturopathic practitioner. And it is my
honor and privilege to bring empowering
information that helps you help
yourself,
especially when it comes to health.
Folks, I want you to make sure that if
you were invited to this program by
somebody specific, you get back with
them, tell them thank you, and also let
them know what you liked best about the
program. And if you have any questions
about anything that is presented,
they're going to be your first point of
contact. As we are part of an amazing
community, a resource for an amazing
community. We want to make sure that
those that are shared this program by
somebody specific actually gets back
with the person that shared this program
with them. Now, if you're out there
watching us on any of the different
platforms, make sure that you subscribe,
send us some love, share. That's the
best way that we are able to get this
information out to so many people is
because of the amazing community who is
sharing our information and letting
people know
a little bit about what we're going to
be talking about today because you are
not really beyond help. Folks, no matter
what the conditions are, there's always
that little glimpse of help. hope and in
many cases more than just a glimpse. So
folks, we are here and sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com.
Visit our website, sign up for our email
list, and you'll be able to receive our
emails, our newsletters, and
announcements of when we are live,
including what our topics are. And
if you have not been working with
somebody, you found us on your own, feel
free to give our call team a call at
855-9493377.
Now today I am going to be presenting as
I have learned so much over the last 10
years, especially the two years that I
was the personal assistant for Dr.
Wallik and did an internship with him in
not only in helping others but also in
his publications company. I learned so
much and I feel so blessed. So, I want
to continue his crusade, the mission of
letting people know the research that he
spent so many years putting together to
create what really goes deeper than the
symptoms, but root causes. So, let me go
ahead and share my screen. Um, and for
those of you who don't know, we are here
Wednesday, Thursday, and Friday
from 12 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1 to 2
Mountain, 2 to 3 Central, 3 to 4
Eastern, and
there we go. Um,
there we go.
And you can find us on YouTube, Rumble,
anywhere that you have
a place to go for information. Do a
search daily with Doc and Becca. You'll
probably find us. Well, today the
question is, are you really beyond help?
So, so many people have given up because
they think that they're beyond help,
that there's nothing else to try. Well,
if you haven't tried our approach, then
there is something else to try. So,
we're going to be exploring the symptoms
that are linked to nutrition
deficiencies,
and we're going to be going into
understanding nutrition deficiencies and
how missing nutrients can really impact
your health.
So what we're going to be learning today
is how to identify those common symptoms
linked to nutrition nutrient
deficiencies. Understand how the
deficiencies affect different areas of
health. Explore the key nutrients that
your body really does need and discover
steps to support your health and
wellness.
So, let's go with some of the most
common things that I see in my practice.
And Dr. Wall got a lot of these
questions as well as many of our coaches
do.
One of the biggest is fatigue, low
energy, tired all the time, feel like
you can't get enough sleep or sleep is
just not doing its job. You've got brain
fog with trouble concentrating and very
forgetful or even a little
forgetfulness.
It's all signs. And then there's
possibilities of hair loss, thinning
hair or increased shedding, brittle
nails that are weak, rigid, or breaking
easily.
Weakened immunity. Are you getting sick
often or does it take you a long time to
get better when you do get sick?
Mood changes. Are you feeling irritable?
Do you have anxiety or a low mood where
you're just kind of blah all the time?
Lack that excitement that you should be
feeling in life? Do you have skin issues
where your skin is dry or there's acne
no matter what age you're at or just
dull skin? Do you have digestive issues,
bloating, constipation, irregularity in
your bowels?
Are do you have sensitivity to cold?
A lot of people even when it's hot
outside, you get sensitivity. Just the
breeze gives you a chill. Feeling cold
often even in the warm temperatures.
Muscle weakness. Do your muscles ache?
Do you feel weak? Or do you get cramps
in your muscles?
So all of those symptoms are a sign of
deficiency.
And deficiency affects your health more
than you think. So, there's missing key
nutrients that can impact many parts of
your body and your overall well-being,
like your heart. So many deficiencies
can increase the risk of high blood
pressure, anemia, and heart disease. Can
you believe your blood pressure is
related to nutrient deficiencies?
A lot of people don't realize that.
brain function. Lack of nutrients can
affect your mood, your memory, your
focus, and mental clarity. The immune
system,
it weakens your body's defenses, making
you more likely to get sick. These are
all things that are affected by nutrient
deficiencies, folks. Bones and muscles.
The deficiencies can lead to weak bones,
muscles, cramps, poor recovery,
skin, hair, and nails.
Yes, nutrient caused folks or the lack
thereof where may cause dryness,
breakouts, hair loss, brittle nails, and
then again digestive health. So many
people are experiencing things
where the root cause could be just
fixing the digestion
or the root solution is fixing the
digestion because digestion is the root
cause.
So let's look at the hard tissue
problems and the impact of not enough
calcium, magnesium, boron, strronium
can and manganesees can actually play in
the body. So, if you're experiencing
things like arthritis and backachches,
carpal tunnel joint pain, I actually was
able to completely avoid carpal tunnel
surgery. Praise God. Um, where I don't
have any issues with my hands anymore.
Bone spurs. Yeah, I was told I had them
head to toe according to an MRI
uh 22 years ago. Uh brittle nails,
calcium deposits in the blood, cartilage
damage, cognitive impair,
high or low blood pressure,
insomnia,
muscle cramps, the nervous system,
osteoporosis,
PMS, prolonged blood clotting time. Do
you know all of those have to do with
the minerals that I just mentioned?
Even receding gums, restless legs,
kidney stones, ligament damage, tooth
decay.
If you want strong bones so that you can
have a strong life, you've got to
nourish with the foundation, folks. And
remember that knowledge empowers,
wellness connects, and together we heal.
So, let's look at some of the key
nutrients that support the body
at the cellular level. Now, if you're
watching us the other day and I said,
"Well, what can we do to help the body?"
Pharmacist been corrected me and it's at
the cellular level. So, these essential
nutrients work together to support
strong bones, joints, connective tissue,
and overall cellular health. So, we're
looking at calcium,
magnesium, vitamin D, vitamin C. Did you
know vitamin D, vitamin C is important
for strong bones, too? K2, collagen,
zinc, manganese, silica, even omega-3s
help with
supporting the hard tissue of the body.
So, let's take a take a moment and let's
dig into connective tissue. So, it's the
body's support system.
So, do you all know what connective
tissue is other than the body support
system?
It's actually a group of tissue in the
body that supports, connects, and
protects other tissues and organs. It
provides strength, structure, and
elasticity,
acting like the glue that holds the body
together.
So, where is it found?
Well, as we see here, you're looking at
the bones, the cartilage, the tendons,
the ligaments, the fascia, the um
atipose tissue, and I probably said that
wrong, and the blood. Yes, connective
tissue is also in the blood.
So, as we're looking at soft tissue,
because we were just looking at hard
tissue, what's the the hidden impact on
vital organs and systems?
Remember, the body is not individual
systems. It works together as a whole.
So, we're looking at some of the soft
tissue issues
and their problems occur when the body
lacks the essential fatty acids and
selenium. These nutrients are critical
for the structure, function and
protection of every cell
which of course every organ is made up
of cells.
And where where are they found?
Brain and nervous system, heart and
circulatory system, lung and respiratory
system. These are all soft tissue
problems, folks. Liver and
detoxification,
digestive and onion organ health,
immune system. Again,
we've got the hair, skin, and nails.
Part of the connection,
hormonal and rep reproductive health,
eyes,
energy, and overall wellness.
Next, let's look at the blood sugar
imbalances. These are the conditions and
symptoms that may be affected by your
blood sugar not being absolutely where
it's supposed to be.
ADHD, ADHD,
yes, has to do with blood sugar, folks.
Anxiety,
bipolar disorder,
fluctuations in your blood sugar can be
one of the triggers that these things
turn on and off or even the underlying
cause of cardiovascular disease,
depression.
Of course, when you hear blood sugar,
you think diabetes,
dizziness,
high cholesterol,
yes, it's not from red meat. It's not
from dairy.
Hyperactivity,
infertility,
migraines,
moodiness,
night sweats. Yes, blood sugar and night
sweats can be linked.
Obesity and peripheral neuropathy
not always blood sugar but most commonly
blood sugar related.
So the digestive system where it all
starts and all the components.
So the digestive system breaks down food
into nutrients that your body can use
for energy growth and repair.
It starts in the mouth and it continues
through a series of organs as I have
shown here.
So when you've got some digestive
disorders, some of those things might be
considered acid reflex,
allergies. Yes, allergies, food
allergies, seasonal allergies can be
related to the digestive system. Celiac
disease.
Um, for those that have celiac, you
know, gluten, it's not your friend.
Crohn's disease, another one, highly
affected by gluten.
Dermatitis,
which that's like things that you see on
your skin. Did you know that your skin
actually reflects on what's going on on
the inside?
Diarrhea,
diverticulitis,
heartburn,
a hiatal hernia, indigestion,
irritable bowels, leaky gut, seasonal
allergies,
thrush, and yeast infections. So thrush
being a yeast infection in the mouth.
Yeast infections are usually other
places that can be under your arms,
behind your knees, in your privates.
All those things are digestive system
related.
So let's look a little deeper into leaky
gut. We hear about leaky gut these days
a lot. And the root cause that impacts
your whole body.
So the leaky gut is the intestinal
permeability
that occurs when the lining of the
intestines becomes damaged allowing
undigested food particles, toxins, and
bacteria to pass into the bloodstream.
Now, when you got a healthy gut, it's
like the nutrients that are getting into
the bloodstream, it's like a quantum
effect where you've got the tight
junctions. the nutrients they pass full
through but the harmful substances are
blocked
the leaky gut you've got damaged
junctions
undigested food toxins and bacteria leak
through into the bloodstream so chronic
intestinal leakage can lead to synthetic
or systematic inflammation and a cascade
of health issues
So again, when we're looking at leaky
gut, it affects the brain, it affects
the skin, affects the immune system,
digestive system, hormones, joints,
muscles, energy levels.
When you heal your gut, you heal your
life, folks. Supporting your gut can
improve your overall health and help
your body function at its best.
So let's talk a little bit about toxins.
Okay, how are toxins getting into the
body? Well, your environment, your
lifestyle is full of toxins that can
invi in irritate and inflame the gut but
and it weakens the protective barrier
and it disrupts the gut bacteria
which then leads to the leaky gut and a
cascading of health problems. So we need
to work on removing these toxins. That's
the first step to healing. But let's
look at what those toxins may be. So, as
we're looking at envir environmental
pollutants, we're looking at air
pollution, pesticides, herbicides, heavy
metals.
In your home,
are the cleaners that you're using
toxins that are getting into the
digestive system and causing you havoc?
the detergents that you use for your
clothes, your personal care products,
you always want to make sure that you
read those labels.
Smoking and vaping damages the gut
lining. Do you think that maybe it just
goes into the lungs? No,
it actually help reduces blood flow as
well. Then you've got alcohol.
It can irritate and thin the intestinal
lining.
Medications.
Yes, medications can be toxins that are
getting into your system causing havoc
within the body and disrupting the whole
systematic process. Things like the
NSAIDs where
over-the-counter pain relievers,
antibiotics, birth control, PPIs, even
acetaminophen,
which is supposed to be safe, right?
So these toxins are actually weakening
your gut barrier, promoting inflammation
even if it's said to reduce inflammation
and can contribute to leaky gut and
chronic disease.
Now the foods that damage your digestive
system and many common foods can trigger
inflammation, disrupt the gut bacteria
as well and damage the intestinal lining
over time
again leading to leaky gut and digestive
problems. So we want to make sure that
we're choosing those gut friendly foods
and reducing these harmful triggers. Um
that's key to healing.
So, what are some of the most common
foods that can be problematic to some or
most, and even if you don't think they
are, maybe you too?
Gluten and grains, that includes the
wheat, barley, rye, can irritate the gut
lining and trigger inflammation.
Dairy products, milk, cheese, yogurt,
they can cause inflammation and
digestive distress in sensitive
individuals. That's why we if you're
taking in dairy, you want to make sure
that you are getting the best dairy you
can that's not been taken from animals
that are pumped full of antibiotics
um or fed things that they shouldn't be
fed, creating an unhealthy byproduct.
refined sugar and artificial sweeteners.
Do you know they feed the harmful
bacteria
and the yeast
and that leads to imbalance of the gut
flora
and more inflammation.
Processed and ultrarocessed foods they
contain additives and preservatives and
seed oils that damage the gut lining and
harm the gut bacteria.
spicy, acidic, and fried foods. Now, I
know some of those spicy foods are super
high in vitamin C,
but it may be causing you some problems.
So,
take your jalapenos and srano peppers
in small doses because they can irritate
and inflame the gut lining, especially
when consumed frequently. And then
excess caffeine
increases stomach acid and could cause
irritation of the gut lining.
So if you have four or five cups of
coffee and then have to run to the
bathroom and wonder why, that might be a
clue. So these foods can trigger
inflammation again, uh disrupt the good
bacteria, damage the gut lining,
contributing to leaky gut and chronic
health problems.
nutritional deficiencies
that cause damage to your digestive
system. Now, these are not the nutrients
that cause damage. These are the lack of
key nutrients that weaken the gut
barrier that impair repair,
disrupt digestion, and increases
inflammation, making it easier for
toxins and harmful product particles to
enter the bloodstream.
So, we got to focus on restoring these
nutrients that will help heal the gut
lining, improve digestion, and
strengthen overall health.
So some of these nutritional
deficiencies that lead to that weakening
of the gut barrier and impairs repair.
Zinc very essential for gut lining
repair, immune function and reducing
inflammation.
Vitamin D supports immune balance and
gut barrier integrity. Deficiencies in
is linked to increased gut permeability.
Omega-3 fatty acids in general, they
help to reduce inflammation and support
the body, especially soft tissue,
including that healthy gut cell
membrane.
Glutamine, primary fuel for gut cells,
essential for repairing the gut lining
and maintaining barrier function.
B vitamins. So we got B1, B6, B9, B12.
They support energy production,
digestion, nerve function, and reduce
inflammation.
And last but not least, and there are
some more, magnesium. Magnesium relaxes
the digestive muscles. They support
enzyme function and helps regulate bowel
movements.
So, the deficiencies in these nutrients
are going to weaken your gut barrier,
impair repair, and increase
inflammation, making your digestive
system more vulnerable to damage and
disease.
But
we talked about the different systems.
Your body is a whole system.
It's connected, working together.
needing balance and not fractionated
nutrition. Folks, every part of your
body is connected and from your
digestive system to your brain, your
immune system, heart and beyond,
your whole body
at the cellular level needs to be
supported. And
this research is done by Dr. Joel
Wallik, one of my heroes. He actually is
a doctor that I contribute saved my life
because I was a really hot mess.
He has decades of research.
He has shown that health and healing
depends on having all 90 essential
nutrients in the right ratios. That's
why we don't want to do fractionated. We
need to have it in the right ratios
working together as one.
I was taking a lot of nutrition.
In fact, if you counted my bottles, it'd
be upwards of 50 different bottles I was
taking from every day when I found Dr.
Wallik. So, I thought I was doing things
right, but it was fractionated. It was
not in the right ratios, and I was
missing a lot, especially since there's
90 essential nutrients.
There's 60 minerals.
The minerals help to build structure,
regulate processes, and support enzyme
function and detoxification.
We are talking with pharmacist Ben
Monday night. Selenium helps to detoxify
the body.
But as Dr. Wallik says, selenium by
itself is not going to cure you. You
need the 90.
16 vitamins
essential for chemical reactions, energy
production and immune function.
12 amino acids.
These are these build and repair tissue,
support immune function and make enzymes
and hormones.
And then your three essential fatty
acids.
They reduce inflammation, support brain
and heart health, and maintain cell
membranes.
90 essential nutrients. If you add it
all up, it doesn't come up to 90. It
comes up to 91. Yes, I know. But it's so
much easier to say 90 essential
nutrients than it does 91.
So, let me tell you a little more about
Dr. Joel Wallik. He has a bachelor of
science in plant and soil medicine
sciences. He has a doctor veterary
medicine. He worked his way through
veterary school in the pathology lab and
he then obtained three postdocates in
pathology
on over 452
different species including humans.
with what he found. He decided he wanted
to become be able to help people. He
became a naturopathic doctor. So, he is
a pioneer. He's a researcher. He's an
educator. He's an advocate for true
health. For over 50 years, Dr. Joel
Wallik has been a leader in veterary
medicine, human health, and nutritional
science. He's best known for his
groundbreaking research showing that
optimal health depends on having all 90
essential nutrients
in the right ratios working together.
Dr. Wallik has been talking about some
of the things that are just now coming
to the surface in the last five years.
He's been talking about them for five
decades, folks. It's not something new.
Because of his decades of research and
experience, Dr. Dr. Wallik earned his
bachelor of science again his do doctor
of veterary medicine and naturopathic
doctor degrees completed post-docctorate
studies and pathology with more than
five decades of research clinical
experience and education. He has touched
millions of lives around the world
including each and everyone of my
co-hosts and myself.
He created the 90 for life research.
The most recognized work demonstrates
that the body requires 60 minerals, 16
vitamins, 12 amino acids, and three
essential fatty acids. Again, in the
right ratios. I can't emphasize that
enough. I had it all wrong.
And this allows our body to function in
the best. Dr. Wallik is also an author
and an educator. He's actually authored
27 different books. I was honored to
help him with three of them.
He is the author of the best-selling
book Dead Doctors Don't Lie and many
other books and education materials
translated into multiple languages.
He's also the founder of Young.
He the it's a company that's dedicated
to providing advanced nutritional
supplements based on his research and
the belief that people can live longer,
healthier, and more fulfilling lives.
He is also the inspiration of the Daily
with Doc because he was our premier
guest
um
reaching millions which just blows me
away and I am so thankful to each and
everyone of you because you're part of
that.
Dr. Wallik's mission is simple folks.
Educate, empower, and inspire
people.
You can take control of your own health
naturally.
And it's simple. When your body has what
it needs, all 90 essential nutrients in
the right ratios, your body can do what
is designed to do, heal, function, and
thrive.
So, let's look at some good foods and
bad foods. These are foods that Dr.
Wallik found to be harmful as far as the
bad foods go. Some lists say 10, some
lists say 12. Adding soy and corn to the
bad um to make the 12.
But again, this is based on Dr. Wallik's
findings.
Wheat, barley, rye, buckwheat, oats,
even oatmeal, even gluten-free oatmeal.
All fried foods. You want to make sure
that you boil, broil, or bake instead.
bottled oils because they oxidize which
causes inflammation and damages the
cells.
Burned and well done red meat, you want
to stay away from that. You also want to
stay away from deli meats, bacon that
have nitrates in them. One of the
stories that Dr. Wall tells about when
he was first working in the pathology
lab. Everybody had gone on Christmas
break and he had stayed in the lab
because he couldn't afford to go home.
And a farmer brought to him um some dead
lambs where he had lost 500 in one
night.
And it all had to do he through his
taking the autopsies uh their thyroids
were all swollen.
Ting he did water samples and found that
there were nitrates
in the water that they were
had available to them and that was from
runoff from the farms around using
nitrates as fertilizer.
So, if you've got thyroid issues,
you really need to pay attention to the
labels and make sure that you're
eliminating those nitrates that are
added so frequently to food, especially
processed foods.
And then baked potatoes. And people are
say, "Yeah, but potatoes are so good.
They're high in potassium." Well, it's
the skins. And Dr. Wallik justifies it
is the skins become crisp and crunchy
when they're baked.
That crisp and crunchiness
along with burnt meat and fats
contain acryummites.
Acryummites, you can look it up on
pubmed.gov,
are linked to cancer.
So if you want to reduce your risk, I
personally would reduce my intake.
So pretty much nothing when it comes to
those bad foods. Now let's look at the
good foods. And I love to focus on the
good side because there are so many
things. As long as I focus on the good
side and don't put the stuff on the bad
side in my cart, I've got a home full of
healthy, nutritious food.
We're looking at eggs, fish, chicken,
pork. I limit my pork. Dr. Wallik
actually limits the pork. A lot of
religions limit pork, but lamb, beef,
especially if you're rare, medium rare
on your cooking of your steaks, beans,
and mixed nuts. No peanuts. As Dr.
Wallik shares that peanuts is what he
found to be the common denominator
of the bears and zoos around the world.
And when when he went searching he found
that there were aphletoxins
in the peanuts where they were being
stored that was causing liver cancer in
the bears. So we want to make sure that
we are being very
uh mindful when it comes to our nuts and
peanuts are not a nut.
gluten-free carbohydrates like rice,
millet, quinoa, couscous from millet
only. And then non-GMO corn he has on
the list as well. Some people have a
hard time digesting corn, especially if
your digestive system is compromised. So
after you go to the bathroom and you had
lot of corn the night before and you
still see chunks of corn in the toilet,
you've got a digestive system, folks.
and it has an issue.
And then vegetables and fruit.
Now, for those that are concerned about
blood sugar, you do want to be mindful
of your fruits and even some of your
vegetables.
Make sure that you are eating those lo
low glycemic fruits and vegetables.
So when you understand that your body
understand your body and give it the 90
essential nutrients in the right ratios,
you give yourself the power to heal,
function, and thrive.
We have to feed our bodies well if we
want to live well, folks.
We want to be informed, not influenced.
Be intentional
every day. Not sometimes, not once in a
while, not four days out of the week,
but every day. We want to be consistent,
keep showing up for ourselves, and be
empowered because you do have the power
to make these decisions.
Now, we would love for you to subscribe,
share us some love, and share our
programs with others. This is the Daily
with Doc and Becca program where we do
share inspiration, education, and
empowerment to help you live your best
life. We also would love for you to
share our parent
station, which is Critical Health News,
which many listeners have heard Dr.
Wallik and the dead doctors don't lie
show um that put together by critical
health news or on critical health news
including on George Norory and coast to
coast.
So please like and share that channel as
well and visit our website
dailywithdoc.com.
Sign up for our email list.
You'll find the good foods bad foods
list there. When you sign up, we're
making it set up so that you can
actually choose to have the good foods,
bad foods list emailed to you, choose a
food diary. You get that when you sign
up as well, and exclusive updates and
more. So, I just want to thank each and
every one of you for being part of the
empowered community.
And if you're wondering how can I get
the nutrients in the right ratios that
will support a healthy digestive system
because that's where the foundation is.
You go to dailywithdoc.com
or go to 90.withdoc.com
and get your healthy body digestion
pack. I like the 2.0 personally or it's
a foundation plus digestive support. So,
you're getting your 90 essential
nutrients in these five products that
also support the healthy digestion,
energy, and well-being. They supports
bone and joints, probiotics, and enzymes
for digestive health. It is possible to
feel the difference in just a few days.
And again, that is the healthy body
digestion pack. So it's the start pack
which is these three osteo tangi and efa
plus and then the digestive pack adds in
the ultimate enzymes and ultimate flora
eex
and
add in the ultimate selenium.
The ultimate selenium and its co-actors
help the body through so many different
functions. And Dr. Fwalik found that one
of the leading causes of cardiomyopathy
and sudden infant death syndrome
and heart attacks in young individuals
and cancer in any age.
all linked back to low selenium when he
was looking at the autopsy reports.
So, might be a good idea to add that in
as well.
I just want to thank each and every one
of you again for being here with us on
Daily with Doc. Um, I'm gonna go through
and see if there were any comments or
questions
as I am so thankful for our team as they
are putting the comments and questions
in here. Annette
um says, "I can't rid my bladder of
ongoing cyitis. I eat according to Dr.
Wallik's list." So there is something
that is
causing inflammation within the system.
I would absolutely get back with your
the person that shared this program with
you Annette. Ask them for Dr. Joanne
Conway's gut flora reset or the 20-day
gut protocol. Um and start with that.
make sure that the
gut the well the whole gut flora is
where it's supposed to be. Um
and then also asked for a bottle of
Killer Biotic and Super KB,
two products that I've recommended with
many of my clients that have been very
helpful with um multiple different
bladder conditions, including cyitis.
Um, and just as a reminder that this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician. It is
for educational purposes only. The FDA
requires us to say this, but folks, when
you give your body what the body needs,
the body itself can do some amazing
things.
And let's see, Harry, um, this needs to
be put into an education system,
Rebecca, in a book form. Oh, thank you,
Harry.
Um, I do have a couple books that I'm
working on and some of this is part of
that. Um, says there are over 39,000
books out now on all different subjects.
You are the light and love. Uh, see, I'm
feeling love from Australia. Thank you,
Harry.
Miriam asks, "Is there a place that we
can access these slides?" Well, Miriam,
since you are um watching this program,
this program is being recorded and it is
also out on all the different platforms.
So, you'll be able to find it the whole
video um that you can watch over if you
would like or share with somebody else.
And since you are part of my team, if
you want just the slides, reach out to
me and we can arrange that as well. Uh
Olga says, "Diff difficult to be
consistent on Yui products while in the
UK. Not easy to place an order. Been
trying for the past two months." Well,
Ola, I thinking that we may have found a
solution for you. So,
um I'm pretty confident that we found
that solution and that is through using
a US shipper where Youngevity then
processes your orders, sends them to the
US shipper and then the products that
are available here in the United States
are shipped on to you through the
shipper.
Are there any other questions team?
I just want to thank each and every one
of you for being here with us today. Um,
I love being able to put the knowledge
that I've learned from Dr. Wallik into
presentations like this. Um, I have
several topics that I am going to be
preparing and putting together for the
coming
months.
We have some amazing speakers and I want
to make sure that um they share their
knowledge with us also. So if I could
get the team up on the screen with me, I
would greatly appreciate it. I am so
thankful that I don't have to do this by
myself. Kathy says, "Has anyone else
experienced a wonky digestive system
while transitioning from bad habits to
good habits?" Yes, your body is purging
all the bad stuff. It's part of the
detox.
So, yes, that is very common. Um, and if
you do experience, you know, some wonky
digestive stuff, do half doses for the
first few days. Ease your body into it
because when you flood your body with
nutrition,
you're going to be pushing out toxins.
Those toxins can cause flu-l like
symptoms.
So you can ease into it or you can plow
through it and be done with it faster
and let the body start using the
nutrition faster.
Um
and Kathy Dr. Joanne Conaway the last
three weeks have done has done some
episodes on Tuesday nights and I want to
make sure that I share them uh with
those. So, for those of you who um are
having bad digestive issues or have had
eating disorders in the past, make sure
you email us
at
what's the best one?
Questions
dailywithdoc.com.
Again, that's questions with an s at
dailywithdoc.com
and request
access to Dr. Joanne Conway's three
weeks of digestive disorders um talks.
So she has shared some amazing
information last night and also last
week and I still have to listen to the
one prior to that and I will as I am
learning each and every day.
Well again I'm so thankful that I do not
have to do this by myself as today we
have with us two ladies part of the tech
crew. We have Sherry and Ruth Ellen.
Sherry is helping get everything set up,
making sure that the stream continues to
stream out on all the different
platforms and also watching for
questions. Ruth Ellen, my executive
production manager, um she helps with
the
advertising of the shows and also takes
the Zoom, mixes it with the graphics and
pushes it out onto the different
platforms. Um, so thank you so much Ruth
Ellen for doing that. And we have Albert
joining us from South Africa as our
gatekeeper letting people in as yes we
are live
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday from 12 to
1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1:2 Mountain, 23
central, 3 to 4 Eastern. And Albert,
unmute yourself and let us know what
time Daily with Doc can be found in
South Africa.
It is from 9:00 to 10:00 in the evening
>> at night to 10 p.m.
>> And folks, if you're in the United
States and you call in the middle of the
night because we have a lot of night
owls, you may hear that voice as well,
another amazing
all of the people on the screen with me
and part of our co-host team um are
certified holistic health coaches. And
last but not least, we have Miss Speedy
Fingers herself who she is here in the
chat live with us and it's only
available live.
Marilyn putting the information into the
chat so people can take screenshots,
help them write their notes as she types
faster than I can speak and uh that's
pretty crazy. So, thank you so much
Marilyn for all you do as well. And
Nancy, I see your comment. You are very
welcome. Thank you for being part of the
team and being here consistently.
And
awesome. So, oh yes, and Kathy mentions
that she has Dr. Conway's books which
are very good. So, folks, if you are
interested in Dr. Conway or any of her
books and go to her website. Her website
is
uh Marilyn, do you have that handy? I
think it's dranconaway.com
and that's c o n a w a y.com or you can
do a search for her name jan ne that's
Dr. Joanne Conaway.
She is also a registered nurse. Um
retired from the Air Force where she was
in the
and some of the worst um in the heart
and surgery theater as well. Um so she
is also amazing amazing resource. Oh
it's drconaway.com
again. drconaway.com.
Thank you so much Marilyn. Well, folks,
thank you for being with us today. I
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day. No matter what day it is, it's
always a great day, even if you have to
make it. And we encourage you to have a
better by the minute life with us. If
you want to be part of something larger
than yourself, whether you want to
become a health coach or be more aware
of how nutrition can affect the health
for your own knowledge to help yourself,
your family, or if you want to be a
coach and help others, we do have the
certified holistic health coach course
that's offered by the Institute of
Holistic Health. You can go to
coach.dwithdoc
dailywithdoc.com
and that'll give you more information
about certified holistic health coach
course and it does have a payment plan
to make it affordable for pretty much
everybody. Again, that's
coach.dwithdoc.com
and my name is Becca Dukes. Thank you
again for joining us here on Daily with
Doc and Becca. And tomorrow we have Dr.
Dr. Judy Reynolds back with us going
deeper into the science of nutrition.
Until next time, bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, for
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.